les résultats viennent de tomber rt
france ne sera pas mise en demeure une
seconde fois par le csa ce matin à les
représentants de notre chaîne ont été
reçus en audience est entendu par le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel est
cette procédure de sanction s'est
ouverte suite à la diffusion d'un sujet
en avril 2019 dans ce sujet il il est
fait état des déclarations d'un général
russe à propos de la syrie pour rappel
le rapporteur indépendant auprès du csa
avait préconisé de ne pas sanctionner un
autre média et pour en parler maître
david koubbi l'un des avocats de rt
france est avec nous sur ce plateau
david oui bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce soir sur rtl france pouvez
vous nous rappeler dans un premier temps
pourquoi rt france était auditionné par
le csa aujourd'hui alors très
précisément pour les raisons vous venez
d'évoquer c'est à dire que votre
rédaction des journalistes de votre
chaînes ont relayé la parole d'un
officiel
un russe sur le conflit en syrie est le
sujet qui semble avoir inquiété le csa
était très précisément le fait qu'il ait
été cité
or pour ce que j'ai pu revoir
les journalistes de votre rédaction ont
parfaitement bien fait leur travail dès
lors que la source était rappelé que le
conditionnel étaient employés et nous
sommes dans une configuration où
aujourd'hui le csa a décidé fort
heureusement il convient non seulement
de s'en féliciter mais de l'en féliciter
de ne pas prononcer de sanction à votre
endroit qu'est ce qui se jouait pour rt
francise été où les enjeux les enjeux
étaient cruciaux les enjeux étaient de
première importance puisque les
sanctions pouvant être prononcée pouvait
pouvait aller très clairement jusqu'à la
rupture de la convention qui lie la
chaîne arte france avec le csa c'est à
dire au delà
l'arrêt de la diffusion comment est-ce
que le csa finalement a motivé sa
décision de ne pas attribuer de
sanctions rt france il l'a motivé d'une
manière que j'estime des plus saines
dès lors qu'il a rappelé que la source
de l'information qui a été diffusé sur
l'antenne de rtl france était rappelé
que les précautions d'usagé
quand je dis d'usagé c'est-à-dire un
usage journalistique avait été respecté
par l'emploi notamment du conditionnel
je ne tiens pas à être trop technique
dans la réponse que je vous fais mais
pour le dire ainsi que les usages en
alice tic avaient été respectées que
révèle cette décision au fond du csa
c'est un bon signe la procédure en elle
même je ne veux pas être polémique mais
la procédure en elle-même ne révèle pas
n'est pas n'est pas un très bon signal
la procédure en elle même était un peu
étonnante parce que vous savez j'ai eu
l'occasion de plaider ce matin pour le
compte de votre chaîne
c'était le procès du selon puisque vos
journalistes disaient selon un général
russe
voici ce qui a été dit toutes les
chaînes dit selon washington selon
johnson selon poutine selon tram selon
macron donc on ne peut pas faire le
procès du selon vous comprenez ça n'est
pas audible puisque vous citez la
personnalité qui qui en parlent les
enjeux
voilà quelques années ce qu'ils étaient
pour conclure de façon plus globale
cette décision elle est un bon signal
pour vous pour la liberté la pluralité
de la presse à nouveau la procédure non
quant à la décision
c'est un très bon signal parce que le
csa a fait oeuvre et a fait montre
d'indépendance aujourd'hui dans un
contexte qui frappe votre chaîne qu'il
convient de rappeler rt france et est
sujet à des critiques qui ne sont pas
des critiques justifiées qui sont pour
moi des critiques calomnieuse il est il
a été dit que vous n'étiez pas des
journalistes ça vous fera sans doute
réagir au sourire ça vous fait sourire
il a été dit que vous étiez à la solde
d'une puissance étrangère et nous nous
avons rappelé tout au contraire que vous
étiez un groupe de presse français que
vous employez des journalistes français
munis de cartes de presse française et
au delà vous savez de la décision qui
touchèrent tu es aujourd'hui je crois
qu'il ya un sujet qui tient à la liberté
de la presse à la pluralité de la presse
et south aujourd'hui en france vous dit
pardon c'est un ranger aujourd'hui en
france ce manque de liberté de pluralité
en tout cas de la presse c'est quelque
chose que vous observez quand un groupe
de presse français comme le vôtre est
poursuivi devant le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel pour avoir citer sa source
c'est à dire avoir fait ce contrat va y
avoir respecté la charte de munich avoir
respecté la déontologie du journaliste
quand ce dossier est arrivé sur mon
bureau vous savez je suis docteur en
droit de la presse donc je suis habitué
aux sujets qui touchent à la presse en
général et aux droits de la presse en
particulier
gg lui la notification de griefs et jeu
avait du mal à comprendre je n'avais pas
très bien suivi l'évolution de l'opinion
en tout cas de l'opinion politique pas
de l'opinion publique de l'opinion
politique
attaché à alerter et je ne comprenais
pas très bien quels étaient ses griefs à
nouveau vous avez cités sur ce plateau
ou un autre de votre chaîne a été cité
un général russe
il n'y a pas de faits délictueux ici il
n'ya rien qui violent la loi les
règlements la déontologie des
journalistes et la décision qui a été
rendue aujourd'hui par le csa est une
décision qui me semble-t-il fait oeuvre
d'indépendance dans un contexte
politique ou du plus haut niveau de
l'état
je dis bien du plus haut niveau de
l'état jusqu'à des sénateurs des députés
des directeurs de campagne
il y avait comme ça un petit bruit de
fond une espèce de mode qui tendait à
dire que rtr tesfran ce n'étais pas mû
par des journalistes n'étaient pas un
organe de presse français aujourd'hui le
conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel vient
clairement de dire le contraire et il a
eu raison le faire puisque vous êtes lié
au csa par une convention que vous avez
parfaitement bien respecté puisqu'il n'y
a pas de sanction prononcée contre rt
pouvant aller je le rappelle jusqu'à
l'interdiction donc en tant qu'avocat je
me réjouis de cette victoire et je me
réjouis en tant que citoyen français que
le droit de la presse soit respectueux
des libertés d'opinion tels que nous les
aimons dans ce pays
le csa comment est il était saisi il
s'est auto saisie sur cette affaire
comment ça se passe voilà vous savez
c'est toujours un peu compliqué de le
dire mais il y a eu un tweet d'une
ministre qui était sous forme de blague
en lien avec ce ce reportage qui était
le reportage vu comme étant litigieux et
il y a eu des dénonciations que nous
retrouvons au dossier d'opposants russes
qui semble confondre ce qui se passe en
russie et ce qui se passe sur vos
plateaux alors que vos plateaux sont mus
par des journalistes français
ce dont je peux témoigner si besoin en
était encore merci beaucoup david koubbi
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage sur
notre plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
l'un des avocats de rt france merci de
votre habitation